[Applause]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday Pizza
behind me so the Tour de nerdfighting is
coming to an end after three weeks and
last night as we were signing in Seattle
it occurred to me that the last three
weeks have really been like the internet
became IRL it was fun and clever and
crowded and it felt good to be a nerd
and there was lots of talk of Sherlock
and Doctor Who
not to mention enthusiastic singing of
songs about particle physics but he also
liked the Internet it went by really
really fast like there were times on
this tour where I felt like I was just
pressing the down key on tumblr and
seeing more and more and more and one of
the problems with the Internet is that
things go by so fast that it's hard to
really experience them like you and
Katherine and I were talking yesterday
about how we hardly even remember the
2008 Tour de nerdfighting we don't
really remember what it was like or how
it felt so Hank this is for future us
this is what it was like this is how it
felt can you hold this camera yes sir
yeah where would you like me at home
[Music]
I would walk 500 miles and I
No
PETA
Oh
[Music]
the beta to watch the bouncing ball
Oh
[Applause]